أريد أن أسألك وأنا قلق قليلاً
بشأن إجابتك ،
ما يقلقك يأتي بعد ذلك ، ما يقلقني
هو ما
سيحدث في غضون 24 إلى 48 ساعة القادمة
لأن روسيا تحاول ضرب
أهداف بعيدة المدى  إنهم يسحبون
قطع المدفعية إلى مسافة 20 ميلاً
ولا يستطيع الأوكرانيون الوصول إليها
لأنهم متباعدون خارج
ساحات القتال في خاركوف وكيف
ولديهم صواريخ بعيدة المدى حيث أبلغ فريد بليكنز
عن إطلاقه من روسيا في أوكرانيا.
لا يستطيع القائد الوصول إلى
هؤلاء ، ولسوء الحظ ، نعلم أن
الطريقة الروسية للحرب
سيبدأون في مهاجمة أهداف مدنية على نطاق واسع
لأنهم لم ينجحوا أبدًا
عندما يهاجمون الجيش الأوكراني ،
لذا فهم
سيشنون حملة إرهابية  حملة الأرض المحروقة
هذا هو الشيء الذي
يقلقني ولهذا السبب من المهم جدًا أن
يتم تدمير بعض هذه الأهداف
ليس كثيرًا من إعادة الإمداد ولكن
أنظمة الإطلاق الفعلية نفسها إذا كان لديك
حمولة شاحنة من الذخيرة بدون
نيران صاروخ لإطلاقها ليس
في صالحك